[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's up
Haley hi K how John how are you good how
are
you I wish I could be better honestly
well what's
um I was hoping to get some input on how
to best address certain Financial
behaviors in my family while also
financially preparing myself for my
future at the same time
okay go for it unpack that for us right
so I'm 25 I'm set to graduate with my
masters and take board exams um to be a
clinical informaticist in the next year
congratulations I thank you um I did
have to move home due to coid and it
being my graduate year that year a lot
of job opportunities kind of fell off so
okay um I was required to basically get
my it took the time to get myself
financially together
um moving home I realized how awful
really our finances were um I'm kind of
treated like the family Bank okay
emergency fund yes um anytime any
emergency repairs or anything come up
I'm usually the go-to person to go and
fix
it um I've honestly contributed
financially to my family for years the
earliest memory would be 10 balancing
checkbooks helping to pay light or water
choosing between light and
water um do you still live at home and
right now I'm really trying to get
myself in a better place as far as
getting student loan PID paid off which
will be done within the next at least
three or four years
um haly Hy Haley do you still live at
home yes sir okay when are you moving
out I need a
date the target date would be January of
2025 there's no way after all board
exams are over why you got to move that
way
up yeah and you know that
right yes sir yeah can I ask you why
you've why you feel feel like you need
to stay home until that point or why you
felt like you needed to stay home until
that
point um in
2025 gosh I'm sorry I'm trying not to
cry it's okay heavy this is heavy stuff
listen let let me just say this before
you answer it no 10-year-old should be
paying their parents' water bill
period and I'm sorry that you as a
10-year-old had to take that
responsibility
on and it's going to be the 25-year-old
you who's walking across the stage with
a graduate degree I'm so proud of
you it's going to take your 25-year-old
having a hard conversation maybe for the
first time and saying the gravy train
stops
here and then you're going to feel
guilty beyond all guilt and they're
going to come after you and say all the
mean things about
you and they don't get a
vote they've used you long
enough
Fair yes sir okay so when's your move
out
date now would
after exams which would be June of next
year nope let's let's let's help you fig
Let's help you move this up let's help
you move it up are you earning any money
right
now yes ma'am how much are you
earning
approximately 30 I'll say 36 a year
what's that per month what are you
taking home per
month taking for month would least be 21
to 22 okay so okay and 100 sorry I'm I I
got you and you've got your student
loans right how much are
those I'm currently still in school okay
so they're not due great any other debt
that would hold you back no ma'am that's
it no ma'am that's it that's excellent
okay let's start doing some research
this weekend when you get off the call I
want you looking around your area have
you done that yet to see what an
apartment would cost to one bedroom one
bathroom in in a part of town that's
safe and that would get you where you
need to go as far as school is and
everything else is put up a note in the
grad school office and saying roommate
needed
mhm I have and I
honestly I I start and then I back out
because I feel start to feel guilty yes
yeah and so you've probably heard me say
this a hundred times I'm going to say it
10,000 more times before I'm done being
on the air from this point forward I
want you to choose guilt over resentment
every
time and here's why you are choosing to
avoid feeling
guilty and in the process you're coming
to hate your
family
Fair that's fair okay let's don't do
that to
them let's don't do that to them let's
choose to draw boundaries they're going
to keep us safe and keep us whole and
let's choose to separate where it's
appropriate and it's been appropriate
for you for a long long time cuz I could
almost guarantee you that they don't
have their hooks in you just financially
but it's emotionally too
right yes sir
yeah you're worth being
free and your parents got to learn how
to pay their
bills what happens if you
disappear you go get an apartment and
you're out what happens to
them um as far as I know
financially arguing holdes in various
places um there's no retirement anymore
there's I had at one point
started a college fund I did not know
that was liquidated until just before I
was applying to college so your parents
stole from
you
well theyo I want to say it like that
I'm going to they stole from you did
they stole from their
child not
okay I want you to put 60 days on the
calendar and I want you to come up with
a plan even if you have to take some
more
hours and I want you after finals this
semester I want you moving out over
Christmas if that's
possible it's possible you're worth
being free my friend
how does that
sound honestly they're ragging um
they've probably been telling you for a
long time that not only can they not
live without you but that you're nothing
without them
right cloth yeah you
are you have been doing the hard work of
changing in entire family tree not only
by yourself but in spite of all the
people hanging
on you're about to find out you are
stronger than you ever thought possible
and you've grown muscles in places that
most of us never have to cuz we don't
have that kind of trauma and the muscles
aren't to drag them along that's right I
want you to go see your your college
counselor College Counseling Center you
pay into that fee and there's some great
College counselors out there go sit down
and say I want to make a transition plan
it's time for me to get these chains off
my arms and legs and for me to fly on my
own we love you we're so grateful for
you